leftist presidential candidate gustavo
petro wins colombia's election by a
narrow margin the former guerrilla and
current senator will be colombia's first
leftist leader he's edged out his former
opponent or his opponent rather former
mayor and millionaire rodolfo hernandez
petro's win marks a drastic change in
presidential politics for a country that
has long marginalized the left for its
perceived association with decades of
insurgency
[Applause]
victory
a historic moment for colombia as it
votes in its first ever leftist leader
former rebel gustavo petro has vowed to
launch profound social and economic
change
we are writing history at this moment
a new history for colombia
for latin america
and for the world
a new history because undoubtedly
what has happened today with those 11
million voters is a change
what is coming is a real change
petro defeated another maverick
candidate former mayor and millionaire
rodolfo hernandez hernandez had garnered
a lot of support for his candidacy on
tick tock
promising to reduce wasteful government
spending and to go after corrupt
officials his concession speech implored
petro to do the same
hope that gustavo petro will know how to
lead the country that he will be loyal
to his words against corruption and that
he will not disappoint those who trusted
him
petro has a tough task ahead of him
he faces a divided congress likely to
complicate his implementation of the
fiscal and social reforms his supporters
are counting on
let's cross over now to bogota and speak
to dw's johan ramirez
so gustavo petro has come out on top in
the vote what helps him get the leg up
on hernandez
he had a very successful electoral
campaign a very successful communication
campaign because actually he presented
himself as a renovation as a change as a
break we continue to but the truth is
that gustavo petro has been doing
politics in colombia for the last 30
years he wasn't the congress first i
think he was diplomat then he was mayor
of bogota one of the main jobs in
politics in colombia now he's again in
the congress now he becomes a president
but he has very been very successful in
presenting himself as a renovation in
politics on the other hand he was also a
former guerrilla so he was very also
successful in rewriting his past his
opponent rudolph hernandez is a very
rich man and it was easy for petra to to
attack him
of being part of the political
economic elite of the country
so how likely is petro's election um
likely to change colombia's political
landscape
it's a major change let's remember that
his victory represents the first time
that left wing takes power in the
country colombia has been rolled
for decades for mainly two political
parties and this is a major change he
has promises left-wing policies social
policies and there are lots of
expectations on his government that will
start on august 7th so in a little bit
more than a month
all right so it appears colombia is
going through a shift to the left but at
the same time both candidates ran on
platforms rejecting the political
establishment so why are colombians so
dissatisfied with their government
because as i said colombia was ruled for
mainly two political parties for decades
and during decades they didn't they
weren't able to tackle the main problems
of the country colombia went um into a
civil war for more than 50 years
colombia was having fighting against
drug trafficking i mean the golden age
of drug trafficking
and and the governments in this country
weren't able to tackle this problem in
security and just to give you one recent
example last year amid the huge crisis
provoked by the pandemic aiming the huge
economic crisis the government of now
outgoing president ivan duke proposed a
tax reform tax reform to increase taxes
for the middle class it provoked a huge
political uh
crisis and
thousands of people took to the streets
to protest and that moment was a turning
point for gustavo petra to to come out
as a new as a as a possibility and also
robert fernandez as an outsider let's
remember that in this presidential race
all political traditional political
parties were out of the of the race and
that's why because people were
dissatisfied with the elite the
political elite of the country
all right that was dw's johann ramirez
bringing us the latest from bogota thank
you very much